[Music]
i have a hard time believing that a
civilization
of fish would create a coliseum able to
fit thousands of fish inside
shaped in the image of the garbage that
rains down upon it
i declare these fry cook games open
there's fire at the end of that fork and
sure i could send fire
under water but my greater concern is
the metal fork heating up while this
fish ran a great distance this has to be
painful
so they made this poor fish go all the
way back out here re-light the torch and
run
all the way back into the coliseum and
up the stairs to light the beef
not a bunch of [ __ ] flame on fish
guy
survives this arriving late to a
sporting event so
tank top fish runs forward with the
bendy part of the straw here but when
it's thrown the bendy part moves up here
and i think if the straw flips around
like that
it means someone is cheating no one and
i mean
no one should [ __ ] around with a deadly
gelatinous
cube why would a fish be wearing
headphones there's no traditional ears
there to cover
that's not how you douche your crabs
away oh one plankton won the hearts of
millions
by performing this perfect onion ring
routine
why would an onion ring routine even be
an event plankton is the only one small
enough to be supported by the rings so
no one else could even compete against
him
blowing your competition to get ahead to
bring home the gold
is to bring honor and glory to the
krusty krab
this would seem far more interesting if
the gold medal weren't given to anyone
on the winner's podium
they don't let just anybody be a fry
cook tell that to the waffle house we're
an elite car
don't come on you're just flipping
patties
actually no spongebob is cooking fries
because he's a fry cook being a paddy
flipper requires a whole other set of
qualifications and at least two more
years of study abroad
fingernails fingernails fingernails not
pictured on either patrick or spongebob
fingernails i cannot believe what i am
hearing
how can you hear it you don't have ears
either spongebob would be the fry cook
champion at tv sins
are you ready to do a die crab talking
to your stds
i gotta get out of here i mean you're
not trapped you could swim
upwards swim fish swim backward
babybjorns
check it out i've been working for the
chum bucket for almost five
minutes does this event not have any
rules not only would patrick be a
last-minute edition which
shouldn't be allowed but he's also
technically never cooked to fry since he
was only hired five minutes ago
so how is he qualified why go through
the trouble of changing clothing for a
competition and
not update your shoes to something
athletic the tread on these tap shoes
has to be terrible
and no i'm not certain they are tap
shoes
get your face sticks here
commercializing cannibalism
and toasted almonds that's unexpected
considering someone had to haul the tray
of toasted almonds out here
it shouldn't be surprising at all what
is surprising is the infrastructure that
would allow almonds to be imported from
above the sea to get to bikini bottom in
the first place
sure the toasting too but we gave up on
sitting fire underwater a long time ago
that cone should be totally covered in
chocolate after submerging it in the
chocolate tank
you know it i know it and the person
getting this lame cone with a shockingly
tiny dollop of chocolate on top knows it
as pat's butter pats retract they would
in fact leave the pith of pat's paths
permanently
aggressively massaging fabric rather
than muscle tissue wwe
starfish don't have tongues who writes
on an employee name tag and pencil
plankton really is evil
also where did the name tag reappear
from when patrick first ripped off his
wrestling robe he no longer had it on
his chest
my name's not frank
hi not rick i'm dad i don't like
you i don't like you more twitter
yellow pink
nothing says i love you more than the
color of your underwear
hallmark really [ __ ] up when they let
that one slip through the cracks
they really made an ass of themselves
they're now the butt of all jokes
okay i'm done mma
you know these were white when i bought
them ending your episode on a urine joke
which actually allows us to end our
video on a urine joke that really takes
the piss out of the whole thing
huh you could say you're in line for a
sin removal
okay now i'm really done
for fish sticks must be eight fish i
declare these fry cook games
open
[Applause]
give me back that fish give me that fish
those of you with weak constitutions may
want to leave the stadium i gotta get
out of here my name's
not frank
my name is